de l'ouest se déroule à stockholm et dès
le début je tiens à remercier nos hôtes
se doit et le ministre affaires
étrangères de la suède
pour l'organisation excellente de cette
réunion et comme vous le comprenez dans
les conditions exceptionnelles de la
pandémie mais en tout cas cette
rencontre en présentiel a été très bonne
nous avons vers ouvertement et en détail
discuter des problèmes de l'eau et se et
notamment des questions d'actualité
la disposition la situation est complexe
on peut même l'a qualifiée de compliquée
et on constate des tendances négatives
qui se développe et qui concerne la
coopération et la sécurité en europe et
à mon avis
on voit la nécessité
de renforcer les capacités de l'ess pour
lui rendre son rôle d'organisation
capable d'assurer la sécurité en europe
encore une fois nous avons exprimé
notre préoccupation vis-à-vis de la
volonté d'un certain nombre de pays
d'imposer leur nouvel ordre fixé selon
des règles qu'ils ont déterminer
eux-mêmes et que promeuvent un certain
nombre de pays occidentaux
et au fond ils promeuvent une approche
discriminative sur ce faire nous nous
insistons sur la nécessité de respecter
le droit international qui a établi des
règles universelles pour tous les pays
de notre planète en ce qui concerne la
sécurité militaire dans la région euro
atlantique elle continue de se dégrader
il ne reste plus qu'un seul accord entre
la russie et les etats unis sur la
limitation des armes à portée
intermédiaire
le traité ciel ouvert a été mise en
pièces par nos partenaires américains et
cela suscite des préoccupations pour
tout le monde mais peu
sont l'audace de dire vraiment d'où
vient le problème
donc on constate qu'un certain nombre
d'accords ont cessé de fonctionner il ya
l'activité de l'otan
qui favorise l'escaladé des tensions à
nos frontières qui suscite notre
préoccupation
on doit s'attendre d'incidents dangereux
il ya des mesures concrètes qui ont été
formulées et le potentiel
de l'otan en europe orientale ne cesse
d'augmenter à proximité des frontières
de la russie
il y à des déclarations menaçantes qui
sont prononcés à notre encontre
et l'activité de l'eau et se
mérite d'être suivi psy et lors de la
session plénière et lors de mes contacts
avec mes collègues occidentaux
j'ai souhaité vouloir éclaircir toutes
ses positions et notamment celle qui a
été annoncée par le président poutine
lors de la réunion du collège des
des affiches du mystère affaires
étrangères de la fédération de russie il
a rappelé encore cela hier au kremlin et
donc nous avons dîné des initiatives qui
visent à limiter toute aggravation de la
situation de façon à éviter l'apparition
de nouvelles menaces aux frontières de
la fédération de russie et cet objectif
de promouvoir
résolution visant à éviter une extension
de l'otan vers l'est et d'éviter
l'installation de nouveaux armements qui
seront directement qui constitueront
directement une menace pour la
fédération de russie le président l'a
rappelé hier et aujourd'hui j'ai attiré
l'attention sur le fait que nous sommes
prêts à respecter des accords qui vont
assurer la sécurité de tous les
participants nous ne voulons pas d'eux
privilège unilatéraux mais nous voulons
que ces accords soient sérieusement
considérer non pas pour que certains
soient repoussées d'un côté comme nos
collègues occidentaux l'ont fait souvent
notamment avec leur promesse de ne pas
étendre l'otan vers l'est et savait déjà
à l'époque
de la réunification allemande il avait
été clairement promis que les structures
militaires de l'otan ne s'installerait
pas sur la partie orientale de
l'allemagne et donc il ya l'acte
fondateur signé entre la russie et
l'otan qui avait validé cela et dont il
ya des formes de d'obligations
politiques qui n'ont pas été respectées
par les pays occidentaux et donc ses
engagements qui ont été rappelés par le
président hier font que nous voulons
qu'ils aient une un caractère
contraignant juridique pour l'ensemble
des signataires nous avons des comptes
des propositions concrètes pour nos
partenaires occidentaux et nous
demandons que ces questions soient
envisagées de façon la plus sérieuse
aujourd'hui lors de la réunion nous
avons parlé aussi des sujets de
préoccupation
notamment le les infractions aux droits
linguistiques et des minorités
notamment en ukraine avec la
glorification du nazisme la promotion de
d'opinion alternative sur les
résultats de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et des pressions sur les médias et cette
organisation qui est qualifiée
d'organisation de sécurité en europe
voit
apparaître de nouveaux de nouvelles
sources de menaces et un dialogue
politique qui ne se fait pas
contrairement au traité qui avait été
conclu on voit aujourd'hui manifestement
les
des convergences d'intérêts qui devrait
se faire aujourd'hui
il ya notamment des projets de
déclaration
notamment en utilisant
la façon de condamner l'usagé d'internet
pour la promotion du terrorisme
malheureusement nos partenaires
occidentaux n'ont fourni aucun argument
concret face à 1,3 pozzoni ils ont
retiré ce sujet des discussions dans la
mesure où en tout cas c'était évident il
disait que c'était justement parce que
la russie avait proposé une telle
progression bonne initiative et donc il
est important ici d'avoir un dialogue
ouvert et heureusement il a pu se tenir
en face à face et l'évaluation des
problèmes qui s'accumulent aujourd'hui
ont été entendus par les participants et
on sent qu'il ya un intérêt pour que
cette crise puisse être résolu et que
nous puissions agir ensemble dans le
cadre de l' os
nous avons parlé de la situation
en afghanistan et des conséquences pour
l'ensemble de l'asie centrale et des
pays de cette zone nous avons énoncé
notre approche sur ces questions et qui
ont été traités au sein de
l'organisation de la coopération de
shanghai ocs sein de l'opération de
coopération
eurasiatique et il ya un certain nombre
de
mesures concrètes qui ont été proposées
pour soutenir les pays d'asie centrale
puisse résister à la menace de la
pression migratoire
dont peuvent se servir les terroristes
et donc nos alliés doivent être protégés
de sept
de cette menace est donc ces
organisations eurasiatique ont justement
pour but de travailler nous avons appelé
nos collègues de l'ocf de travailler sur
des plans sur la base de ce qui se fait
déjà en faveur de ces pays voisins sur
le terrain
sur les autres questions oui nous
souhaiterions améliorer l'efficacité de
l'ouest en matière de lutte contre les
menaces transnationales ce soit le crime
organisé les narcotrafics le terrorisme
et à cet égard nous voudrions
avoir des réunions plus fréquentes au
sein de cette structure notamment au
niveau des comités qui travaille sur les
la lutte antiterroriste un certain
nombre de documents
qui devait être adoptée
est proposée par notre ministère ont été
supprimé de l'ordre du jour parce que
certains de nos collègues occidentaux
ont se sont manifesté de façon très
agressive ou contre nous avec des
intérêts
interprétations sur les questions de
genre
cela ne correspond pas au but de notre
organisation alors que finalement au
total nous avons adopté qu'un seul
document sur les questions de des
efforts de dresser
en matière de
réaction face aux changements
climatiques
et finalement il n'y a rien de plus à 6
il ya quand même eu une décision qui a
été adoptée sur la transnistrie
et je les ministres des affaires
étrangères de russie etats unis et
france ont adopté une déclaration sur le
haut karabakh
qui salue la médiation de la fédération
de russie
évidemment nous voudrions voir des
résultats plus tangibles de ce travail
notamment une politique d'une
déclaration politique
si que nous n'arrivons pas adopté
simplement parce que certains au lieu de
se concentrer sur
les problèmes européens généraux les
problèmes de sécurité cherchent au
contraire
de mettre dans cette déclaration
des questions peu importantes ou de
faire allusion à tel ou tel conflit
extérieur à cette décision nous avons
adopté aussi une déclaration 8 décision
selon laquelle en 2025 la finlande va
avoir assuré la présidence de
l'organisation ce sera les 50 ans des
actes de l'acte final d'helsinki et
ensuite la précédente sera celle de la
pologne et la réunion se fera dans la
ville de lodz en pologne je voudrais
dire aussi que nous avons parlé de
l'ukraine encore une fois ici notre
position est connue elle a été annoncée
plusieurs fois nous avons attiré
l'attention sur la le rôle de l'eau et
c'est eux et sur la nécessité de s'en
tenir aux accords de minsk et de suivre
justement le mandat des mission
d'inspecteurs de l'ouest sur le terrain
et tout cela est clairement stipulé
c'est que kiev doit avoir un dialogue
direct avec lougansk est
donetsk or on voit que le ce n'a pas
toujours une approche objective de
l'exécution de son mandat et j'espère
que dans la tête décision physio et cela
sera formulée et le secrétaire général
de l'oif 6e
et le ministre suédois des affaires
étrangères
entendra notre argument en ce sens sont
donc encore une fois nous sommes intérêt
à intéresser à ce que l'ol reviennent
dans l'esprit d'helsinki qui c'est la
base en 1975 qui a donné naissance à
cette organisation et qui implique tous
les pays de notre région sans exception
donc l'organisation elle même doit
encore une fois je le souligne d'être
traités de coopération et de sécurité et
non pas elle ne doit pas renforcer les
contradictions
cesti un monsieur lavrov décès de blé au
lit durant ces dernières semaines ne
landes et le directeur des sièges sont
venus chez nous à moscou selon eux les
réunions étaient constructives mais
récemment leurs besoins américains ont
durci le ton à l'égard de moscou qu'est
ce que c'est que ça sent double jeu à
quoi ça mène
en gros ce n'est pas juste avant leur
voyage mais aussi pendant leurs
déplacements et ils ont parlé des
contacts qu'ils avaient eues dans
l'esprit que vous venez d'évoquer ou
insistons sur le goûter constructif mais
malheureusement tout cela se résumer au
fait que la russie doit telle chose
est-elle chaude quelque chose et toi
qu'elles respectaient l'accord
d'aujourd'hui pendant la discussion
anthony blinken le secrétaire d'état
américain a commencé à énumérer les
revendications vis-à-vis de la russie à
propos des accords de miss notamment le
cessez-le-feu sur la ligne doc times le
retrait des armements lourds
la fin de l'ingérence économies dans le
dos de bath mais
évidemment je lui ai tout expliqué et je
lui ai les cités au cours de notre
rencontre bilatérale jouer expliqué où
on en est d accord de minsk et que
toutes ces questions doivent se faire
directement par un accord et des
discussions directes entre kiev lugansk
à donetsk mais ce côté de possession de
vouloir
faire incomber toute la responsabilité
des accords de minsk à la russie des se
constate chez tous les responsables de
l'otan donc on a ici néanmoins et
on en a parlé de façon tout à fait
professionnel avec le secret d'état
aujourd'hui sur l'ukraine en tout cas
les américains
se disent prêts à aider à l'exécution
des accords de mise même si l'interprète
pas toujours les choses
que ce qui est écrit dans le texte mais
ceci dit
on peut dire que peut il faut profiter
de cette possibilité parce que ils
peuvent avoir une influence décisive sur
kiev et en même temps ils prétendent
pas vouloir étendre le format de
normandie mais en tout cas je pense
qu'il faut profiter de ce système il
faut d'accord nous sommes pas contre
mais il faut commencer par définir
quelles aides quelles sont les modalités
de coopération de coopération ici il ya
les accords de minsk il faut c'est pas
qu'il faut les interdits interprété
c'est qu'il faut les lire et faire ce
qui est écrit d'ailleurs compte tenu de
ces déclarations politiques à notre
encontre nous avons spécialement diffusé
auprès de tous les participants le texte
de la résolution
sur important et à ceux d'accor et le
texte des accords eux mêmes et la
déclaration des pays garants
c'est-à-dire russie etats unis france
allemagne qui est j'ai demandé à mes
collègues avant de faire de nouvelles
déclarations sur les questions du
créneau de bien analyser ces documents
en détail dans la déclaration des quatre
dirigeants tant que la résolution que le
texte des accords eux mêmes je pense que
peut-être il y aura ils comprendront
enfin qu'il faudra qu'il faut changer de
rhétorique de toute façon nous sommes
toujours prêts à tout contact nous ne
fuyons aucun contact mais il faut bien
comprendre ce que nous voulons encore
une question ce qui est vous voyez les
navires dans le mer noire et la
concentration des matériels militaires
après des débats c'est ce que je vous le
voyez comme les maillons dans seule
seule chaîne n'a qu'un seul objectif
c'est contenir la russie cela se
s'exprime notamment dans les affaires lé
que qui sont évoqués dans votre question
nous rappelons encore une fois à nos
collègues
europe non occidentaux que ça fait deux
ans qu'il refuse d'analyser en détail
les propositions que notre état major a
proposé pour examen au pays de
l'alliance de l'organisation
de l'alliance atlantique et là encore
une fois il ya des questions de retrait
des armements de déroulement des
manoeuvres militaires deuxièmement
déterminer les distances maximales de
rapprochement des navires et des
aéronefs et ensuite il ya les mesures de
sécurité dans la baltique par exemple
les accords sur que les avions
militaires se soit branche leur
identificateur amis ennemis au cours des
vols et tout cela bien évidemment c'est
notre volonté sincère pour éviter une
désescalade or justement les refus de
cette volonté le
cette mauvaise volonté de l'otan casse
la
confiance mais en tout cas nous allons
continuer à faire en sorte d'être
entendu mais l'essentiel encore une fois
c'est notre sécurité par conséquent si
l'otan va a continué à fuir le dialogue
va
continuer
à refuser les idées proposées par le
président poutine nous prendrons les
décisions qui s'imposent en inde et en
toute indépendance pour défendre notre
intégrité territoriale et d'autres
souvent journal commercial je vais
revenir si cela prouve ma question
concerne sujets déjà abordés
s'agissant du ruffus probable des états
unis et des alliés de présenter des
garanties de sécurité à la russie que se
passera-t-il ont ce cas avez vous un
plan b nous disons non pas qu'on me
donne des garanties de sécurité mais
comme l'a dit le président poutine l'a
dit hier c'est que révèle aux bords y
ont des
garanties générale pour chacun des
participants de ce processus europe 1 et
là je cherche même pas à deviner
à envisager même que les pays
occidentaux refusent je pense que tout
le monde a entendu le message du
président poutine ont bien pris
conscience que notre proposition tout à
fait sérieuse et nous nous la couche ont
sur le papier actuellement et je cherche
pas à savoir quelles seront les
réactions mais en tout cas ce qu'il faut
c'est regarder
de quelle façon les pays occidentaux
regarderont seront ils sérieux seront
ils s'insèrent dans la considération de
nos propositions s qui continueront à
gonfler les muscles et à me faire une
propagande de militaires agences ria
novosti
bonjour monsieur le ministre j'ai des
questions
récemment la vice secrétaire d'état des
états unis avec thaïlande avait déclaré
que chez les russies tenter de
déstabiliser l'ukraine est le subir et
des sanctions sans précédent les
commentaires pour vous donner à cet
égard et quelle sera la riposte du
moscou si de telles sanctions ont été
imposées et la deuxième partie de ma
question alors lors de votre entretien
d'aujourd'hui avec messieurs blinken
vous avez parlé de travail des missions
diplomatiques
est ce que ça signifie que à l'expulsion
des diplomates russes sera arrêté et si
les rencontres d'experts sont prévues
quand est-ce que
ensuite on cerne ce qu'a dit madame
drone s'est d'ailleurs c'était respecté
par monsieur blinken lui-même mais un
certain nombre d'autres délégués et
notamment par les allemands c'est à dire
qu'il y aura des sanctions sans
précédent vous savez que chaque fois
quelque chose se produit la première
fois c'est toujours jean louis donc
c'est toujours sans précédent simplement
nos collègues occidentaux ont perdu la
culture du dialogue la culture des
échanges diplomatiques de la recherche
d'un consensus de travailler de façon
constructive dans le respect des équipes
d
dans l' équilibre des intérêts est tout
de suite ils introduisent des sanctions
pas seulement vis-à-vis de nous mais
pratiquement partout
il dresse des sanctions contre un nombre
de pays dont la politique dans le sang
voire à leur vision et à ce moment là
ils introduisent des sanctions contre
ceux qui désobéissent mais
malgré tout j'espère bien que cela
ne manifeste pas le fait dramatique que
les pays occidentaux ont perdu le sens
du dialogue mais que simplement cette
humeur
russophobe dans l'otan et dans l'union
européenne j'espère que cela ne
débouchera pas sur une confrontation
et j'espère que ces pays travailleront à
ce pourquoi l'auteur été créé c'est à
dire s'il ya des sanctions infernale
comme ils le disent bien sûr que nous
réagirons on ne peut pas laisser ça
passe et comment nous réagirons nous
verrons je n'ai pas envie maintenant de
chercher à deviner à
manipuler des sanctions sectorielle
économique etc c'est une impasse et cela
se retourne contre ses propres
initiateurs ces mesures illégitime en ce
qui concerne les personnes oui nous
avons rappelé à nos collègues
que cette spirale
de restriction mutuelle
lancé par obama avant deux semaines
avant son départ de la maison blanche
est simplement pour
rendre glissant le terrain de trump on
voit les conséquences sur quoi sous
c'est absolument inacceptable et ça
casse tous les canons
diplomatique les conventions et le fait
que les états unis ont conquis ont pris
sous leur
contrôle notre propriété diplomatique
aux états unis et c'est à dire
il ne laisse même pas entrer sur le
territoire de ses missions diplomatiques
ne laisse pas les diplomates russes
entrées pour voir ce qui s'y passe
que cette ces mesures de restrictions
unilatérales introduite par les
américains vont à l'encontre des
conventions diplomatiques et ça fait par
exemple ça fait que trop nos diplomates
ne peuvent travailler que trois ans sur
le territoire américain on nous a
expliqué que c'était la pratique
américaine la réponse est très simple
c'est que notre
réponse est que de ne pas refuser de
personnes sur le terrain or ils
utilisaient 400 employés russes ici donc
nous avons mis fin à ce droit
donc oui on voit aujourd'hui c'est un
cercle vicieux on peut pas ne pas réagir
on peut pas leur accorder
la supériorité unilatérale et donc
j'espère que nos collègues américains
comprendront que cela ne va ni dans leur
intérêt ni dans notre intérêt de la
façon et les effets qu'ont dit les
consultations d'experts
et notamment dans le cadre de la
rencontre entre les deux présidents ces
rencontres se poursuivent un nouveau une
nouvelle série de consultations doit se
faire à la fin de cette année au début
de la prochaine mais pour l'instant nous
ne voyons pas tellement de bonne volonté
de la part de nos partenaires
dans le sens de mesures constructives
nous avons fait des propositions et
aujourd'hui je le redis encore à donner
anthony blinken je propose d'annuler
toutes ces restrictions de repartir sur
une bonne base des pour que nos missions
diplomatiques plus travaillés
fonctionner normalement c'est à dire
s'il vous plaît
je représente la télévision géorgienne
tamara excusé mais s'il vous plaît
lorsque vous avez demandé de participer
à la conférence vous avez par les russes
c'est un problème c'est un problème non
mais son fonds des journalistes russes
qui sont présents
je peux parler anglais monsieur le
ministre et de l'abbé traduire vous
inquiétez pas qu'ils aiment aussi
l'opéra russe non je vais je vais parler
anglais si c'est possible
d'approcher une fois il faut le dire de
telles de lui mais seul ministre comme
vous le savez
la géorgie et le peuple de la géorgie à
deux on est le seul à pouvoir
neutraliser notre à probable
participation au le temps et les
déclarations faites par messieurs
piscine et par vous même
comment ces lits avec la géorgie
vous savez
je connais ce mantra que répète
l'otan est encore récemment il sollten
berg l'a dit
selon lesquelles seuls les membres de
l'otan et la géorgie et l'ukraine vont
décider
de leur adhésion dans l'otan personne ne
peut se mener cette question cela cesse
et la position
déclaré clairement par ce groupe de pays
et je rappelle que selon le droit
international
il ya des principes un peu différent si
vous les connaissez ça commence par le
principe de base c'est à dire que chaque
pays a le droit de choisir la forme de
don lam dont il défend ses intérêts et
son intégrité territoriale sa
souveraineté et concrètement dans ce cas
il y a des obligations qui ont été
signés au plus haut niveau par tous nos
partenaires occidentaux
l'ukraine la chirurgie selon lesquelles
la
sécurité est indivisible et aucun pays
n'a le droit
n'a lui aucun pays n'a le droit
d'assurer sa sécurité aux dépens d'un
autre
nous avons proposé que ces déclarations
politiques adoptées bleu haut niveau
soient codifiées et qui est le principe
d'indivisibilité de la sécurité soit
juridiquement contraignant contraignant
et que cela soit inscrit dans la
dans le statut des pays membres de l'oie
ce que ça a été refusé et il ya une
explication intéressante on nous a dit
officiellement juridiquement un texte
contraignant je ne peut
concerner que les pays de l'otan alors
on leur dit mais comment comme ça vaut
président vous premier ministre ont
signé ce document qui a un caractère
contraignant est-ce que leur parole n'a
aucune valeur aucune réponse par
conséquent cette mentalité qui a
commencé à se manifester dans les années
90 soit vous êtes avec nous soit vous
êtes avec la russie aujourd'hui se
manifeste aussi dans la position de
l'otan sur la question de
l'indivisibilité de la sécurité
on sait encore une tentative de viser
l'europe de
recruter un maximum de pays dans ses
rangs de les engloutir au lieu d'ajouter
de la sécurité l'alliance devient
non pas monopoly d'
alors que son objectif était d'assurer
la sécurité et la défense mais
aujourd'hui
en engloutissant seppi ça n'a pas ajouté
de sécurité au contraire sa abaissé la
capacité de l'alliance de se défendre
donc aujourd'hui il faut réfléchir non
pas est-ce que je vais rentrer dans une
usine organismes et le reste je m'en
fiche non il faut réfléchir aux
principes que nous avons tous soutenu
que nous avons tous proclamé
quand il s'agit d'assurer
que pour l'union soviétique de respecter
les droits de l'homme nous avons accepté
ce compromis aujourd'hui l'otan voit
qu'il a besoin de toujours plus et qu'il
faut contenir la russie militairement
c'est malhonnête nous avons proposé de
revenir aux fondements sur lesquels
s'est établi la sécurité en europe
c'est-à-dire un dialogue la recherche
d'un consensus d'un consensus et une
sécurité un divisé et je suis sûr que la
géorgie sera à l'aise dans ce contexte
je vous remercie